we glad that you could join us for this
Q&A and my name is uh Pastor Enoch BOGO
and with me is Pastor Randy we're glad
you're here thank you and if you would
kindly open for us with a word of prayer
yes indeed let's pray our loving father
in Heaven we're so grateful to you for
the gift of life and for the honor of
speaking for you cleanse us from all
unlikeness all that is unlike you I pray
and Grant to us the words of wisdom that
those listening might be led into a
closer relationship with you bless
everyone listening and every country
represented by those listening I pray in
Jesus name amen amen and amen thank you
very much we will take our first
question which is how does one conquer
appetite appetite was the problem Adam
had and Eve the first Adam fell on the
point of appetite the second Adam
conquered on the point of appetite and
this is not accidental the devil knows
that through a an an inability to
control appetite he really has access to
someone to control that person appetite
is conquered by delivering up the will
to God and the will is that place where
we make decisions yes no I'll do this I
won't do that this must be yielded to
God constantly the surrender must be
daily when that happens God works in us
to control this tremendous urge called
appetite and there are two very powerful
urges the desire for food the desire for
sexual uh interaction and both are
connected to survival food I Stay Alive
by food sexual activity produce children
the race is preserved and they're very
strong urges put in Us by God but God
also gave us a mind a will which is
designed to control because the appetite
has no mind of its own the appetite is
not a thinking organism it is just a
power that must be controlled it is
controlled by the will placed into the
Hands of Christ when that is done it is
Christ that exercises the power through
us to control those urges which we call
animal passions there's nothing wrong
with them but they must be controlled as
I said by a will surrendered to the
power of Jesus Christ as the Bible says
God works in us to willing to do
according to his good pleasure uh so I
strongly urge anyone with a struggle
with appetite it's not an easy struggle
and God understands that daily surrender
of the will to him and also keep in mind
your body is the Temple of the Holy
Ghost the Holy Spirit and we must
glorify God in our body and in our
spirit and so when you abuse this body
by overeating you're abusing something
that literally belongs to God it does
not belong to you this is literal
language not symbolic and so I urge you
surrender your will to God entirely not
99% 100 do it daily perhaps more than
daily it doesn't take long to say father
I Surrender my will to you guide and
direct me and through that process and
by your own effort the key is divine
power and human effort and the Victory
will eventually be yours amen so what
Pastor you're saying is I come to God
and I ask him I desire to do your will
please give me the strength to live by
it and you make you make an effort make
an effort yes yes you cooperate with God
that is exactly the case amen number two
is what is the right way to Fast And if
someone uh feels angry and they are
tempted they end up eating in the middle
of their period of fasting is this a sin
all right fasting essentially is a
voluntary Act of self-denial you're
denying yourself something you really
really love and need usually people fast
from food because food is what keeps Us
Alive you see and so we fast from it we
deny ourselves that self-denial is a
central tenant of a relationship with
Christ Christ's entire life was one of
self-denial now why do I say that let's
reason in the scriptures in John 8:29
Jesus said and he that have sent me is
with me the father hath not left me
alone for I do always those things that
please him this is self-denial I'm doing
what he wants not what I want we know
that Jesus wanted to do some things of
his own will because he said in the
Garden of Gethsemane father if thou be
willing remove this cup from me
nevertheless not my will but thine be
done Christ's entire life was one of he
fasted from self if I may put it that
way his ultimate actions were all
connected to is this the will of God and
so fasting as I said is voluntary self
denial you may fast from food you may
fast from social media you may fast from
television you may fast from whatever
that may be injuring you never fast from
something that is good you fast as a
spiritual principle to develop to grow a
spiritual exercise if in fasting you
fall and you
eat I won't classify that a sin unless
you had made a promise to God if you
said father for the next N9 hours I will
not eat I promise you I will now you do
that and then you eat you've sinned but
if you decide let me try to fast for 9
hours and you eat you have not sinned
yes you did not keep your word but you
did not make a promise to God but if you
keep trying you will come to the place
where you honor your desires to fast and
as I said earlier it can be from food
television overeating whatever uh sweets
time with your girlfriend your boyfriend
you know whatever going to soccer
watching Arsenal and Manchester United
all of that we can fast from if you're
new to fasting and you want to fast from
food take it
slowly don't go fasting for 3 days and
you've never fasted before God is not an
unreasonable God he calls us to reason
Isaiah 118 fast for the morning meal or
fast from the afternoon work yourself
into it slowly then you may consider an
entire day or two days or 3 days but
ultimately the purpose is spiritual
growth spiritual power Jesus said about
some demons they're not cast out except
by prayer and fasting fasting is an
absolutely essential spiritual exercise
thank you we'll take the next one and uh
the question says will the 144 be part
of those who go through the time of
trouble or does this number repres is is
this number um uh let me come again is
the
1,
144,000 uh part of those who go through
the Great Tribulation or does this
number represent the great multitude
okay there's the great multitude in
Revelation 7:9 and there's 144,000 they
br down by tribes Revelation 5 75 to8 so
two different groups there are some
Scholars who think they're the same
group but the Bible gives evidence
they're two different groups when God
called Abraham in Genesis 17 and gave
him circumcision he said he shall keep
my Covenant therefore then he said every
Manchild among you shall be circumcised
he that is born in the house or bought
with money of any stranger which is not
of thy seed in other words there's the
group biologically attached to Abraham
then there Those whom he bought in those
days people bought slaves so there were
two groups but what United them was all
had to be circumcised and so we have two
groups the tribes directly from Abraham
then we have the larger multitude the
Gentiles who came into the faith but
both saved by the same sacrifice of
Jesus Christ and
[Music]
so we the
144,000 represent those who will be
alive on the
earth before Christ comes in in
Revelation 6 the last verse says for the
great day of his wrath is come and who
shall be able to stand I that's verse 17
Revelation 6 now in chapter 7 we have
those who will be able to stand we have
the 144,000 but we also have a great
multitude but the 144,000 represent
those who will be alive on the Earth
when the earth goes through the time of
trouble and they will endure a time of
trouble that the world has never seen as
we're warned in Daniel 12:1 whether it's
literal 144,000 or symbolic the church
has no fixed position some scholars
believe it is literal number other
scholars believe it refers to the
quality of the character you know 12 X2
144 it is the the the well-rounded
character the symmetrical character of
Christ represented in those who live
during those very very trying times but
either way the 144,000 are not the only
ones who will be saved we have the large
multitude which no man can
number thank
you what is the difference between faith
and
presumption faith is acting upon the
word of God
presumption is acting upon what you
think is right a classic example when
God parted the Red Sea he told the
Israelites to cross they crossed and
they were safe he did not tell the
Egyptians to cross they tried to cross
they were all destroyed we have two
groups one acting by faith one acting by
presumption God called the Israelites to
cross they crossed everyone was safe
when the Egyptian started Crossing when
the entire Army was in the midst of that
Gap then all the waters came back one
act based on faith one act based on
presumption and you cannot have faith
without the word of God faith is acting
upon thus sayth the Lord it isn't just
feeling something it is trusting God to
do what he says faith isn't expecting
God to do what you
say faith is asking God to do what he
says are you following me some people
think faith is God will do what I say no
no no of faith is God will do what he
says you believe that because God cannot
lie presumption is acting upon your own
impulses your own feelings your own
desires and trying to make them the will
of God there's a fine line that I'd like
to maybe ask discuss a little further on
that the devil took Jesus on top of the
mountain he took him on on The Pinacle
of the temp told him it is written his
angels will take charge of you so how
does one differentiate
is this me acting on what God has said
or is this me leading myself into
temptation all right the devil did say
it is written he shall give his angs
charge over thee they shall bear thee up
in their hands he's quoting from um
Psalm 91:1 what he left out is he shall
give his angels charge over thee to keep
thee in all thy ways he left that out
you see because the devil does not want
you or me or you in the ways of God so
he used the scripture
deceptively so if Jesus had jumped in
his
Humanity he would have had two broken
legs a broken hip a dislocated spine
because he would have acted
presumptuously but Jesus said Thou shalt
not tempt the Lord thy God don't do
something you know to be wrong and hope
God will get you out of trouble don't do
that act upon thus sayth the
Lord thank you it must be what God has
you to do and it must be in his line of
duty yes and you discover that as you
study the word constantly a lot of us we
want to know God's will only when a
crisis arises but it's by constantly
living in the word of God we develop the
ability to recognize this is the voice
of God or this is not the voice of God
Jesus said my sheep know my voice you
see because they always listening to it
this is the voice of God we develop the
ability to recognize God's voice by
constantly studying his word and obeying
it you leave out the obedience you will
never recognize the voice of God thank
you we have a next one which is who was
madc melc was a literal human being a
priest in the days of Abraham in Genesis
14 we can go there if you like uh
chapter 14 in that chapter a lot has
been conquered by some armies that came
over from the other side of Euphrates
River and they took lot his possessions
all the people and they departed Abraham
was told of what happened and he chased
after them he defeated them brought back
lot the women the children lost
possessions everything in verse 18 says
and mzc king of Salem brought forth
Bread and Wine he was the priest of the
most high God so we're introduced to
melkisedek a real person who was the
king of Salem some people say melc was
Jesus Christ no Christ has never been
the king the king of an Earthly city mzc
was the king of Salem and he was a
priest on the earth on the earth Jesus
never function as a priest he's
functioning now as a priest in heaven
interceding for us on the earth Christ
was a prophet the prophet of God the
mouthpiece of God not a priest he is a
priest now melkisedek was a priest and
he was a king Christ wasn't a king on
the earth and he wasn't a priest now in
Hebrews 7 melkis DEC is described as
having not mother father or mother or
beginning of life but made like under
the Son of God abideth the king priest
continually because we have no record of
melchisedec's ancestry some people
believe he was Jesus no the Bible uses
that as a symbol of the minist the
Priestly Ministry of Christ there are
three major offices Christ will occupy
Prophet priest and King now listen
carefully my friends are online listen
carefully
Prophet Christ was a prophet but his
prophetic Ministry was based on the
prophetic Ministry of
Moses and so in Deuteronomy 18:15 the
Bible says a prophet will the Lord your
God raise up unto you from the midst of
you of your brethren like unto me Moses
said there'll be a prophet just like me
what made Moses different from any other
Prophet when Miriam and Aaron rebelled
against the authority of Moses in
numbers 12 God said said in verse six if
there's a prophet among you I will make
myself known to him but he said my
servant Moses is not like that I will
speak to him mouth to mouth face to face
now the only other Prophet who had that
was Jesus Christ who was in the bosom of
the father and so Moses said a prophet
will be raised up just like me you must
listen to him in Acts 3:22 the Bible
says for Moses truly said unto the
fathers a prophet shall the god raise up
unto you he referring to Jesus Christ in
verse 26 now melchisedec then is the
Earthly symbol of the Priestly Ministry
sorry Moses is the Earthly symbol of the
prophetic Ministry of Christ so Christ
was a prophet based on Moses's Prophet
prophetic Ministry now I said Prophet I
said King in Acts chapter 2 when uh the
the angel Gabriel came not act chapter 2
Luke chapter 1 when the angel Gabriel
came to Mary that she'd have a child in
verse 31 the angel said and thou behold
Thou shalt conceive in thy womb and
bring forth a son and thou shalt call
his name Jesus he shall be great and
shall be called the son of the highest
and the Lord God shall give unto him the
Throne of his father David when Christ
reigns forever in the earth he' be
sitting on the throne of his father
David which means the kingship of David
is the Earthly symbol of the Eternal
kingship of Christ and his kingdom now
but David is dead Moses died and then
was raised up by God now the other
office is priest melchisedec now who is
a priest in Salem is the Earthly symbol
of the priesthood of Christ going on now
but look at the three offices Prophet
Moses King David priest
mzc when Christ sets up the new world
there will be no need for Prophet when
he sets up the new world there'll be no
need for priest when he sets up the new
world he'll be a king so if one of the
three had to be alive or had to
represent Christ or was actually Christ
it would have to be David because David
represented a status Christ will have
forever but in the new world we don't
need prophets we don't need priests but
we'll have a king melchisedec was a
human being but his priesthood merely
symbolized the higher priesthood of
Christ as Moses as a prophet his
prophetic Ministry symbolized the
prophetic Ministry of Christ and David's
King his kingship symbolized the Eternal
kingship of Christ melkisedek was a real
person he was not Jesus Christ sorry to
take so long to answer that question
thank
you there's a question what should one
do to keep children from running in
church go to Exodus chapter 19 this is
an important question there seems to be
a belief among members that uh God
accepts irreverence from children and
expects reverence from all the people
let's pray again before we go any fur
the father as we continue answering
questions give us the right words dear
God to Enlighten your people but more so
that you may be glorified in Jesus name
we pray amen amen God gives Moses
instructions to inform the Israelites
how to prepare for his coming he's
coming down to Mount Si to bring the law
now here's what he tells Moses to tell
the Israelites read verse 12 and verse
13 of Exodus 19 and thou shalt
you shall set bounds for the people all
around bounds meaning limits uhhuh
saying take he to yourselves that you do
not go up to the mountain okay pause
don't go up to this mountain that's
where I'm coming down this is my area
don't go up keep reading don't go up to
the mountain nor touch it face MH what
whoever touches the mountain shall
surely be put put to death God is saying
if anyone touches this mountain that I
have have reserved for me
that person is dead now let's see how
far the death penalty went read verse 13
not a hand shall touch him but he shall
surely be stoned or shot with an arrow
now listen carefully whether it be
whether man or beast he shall not leave
now pause man or beast that touches that
man is dead question now for those of us
who listening and we reasoning did that
include children the answer has to be
yes
if a child had touched that mountain
dead which means the parents would have
to monitor their children because
children being children they wander
around they run around they have no
thinking capacity as an adult has they
would have touched that mountain and
been struck dead by a holy God who never
does wrong so the parents had to monitor
their children and monitor their animals
because animals also wander around God
is a serious God he requires reverence
and respect and the church is not a
playground but some cultures they almost
worship children so the children can do
anything they want the children run
around the church and people just sit
there and smile no no no no no this is a
church and the people ought to instruct
their
children children learn much more than
we think my good pastor they understand
more than we think when they are trained
they act according to their training and
if children are trained at home
to respect the Church of God they will
respect the Church of God God is God no
matter what the age limit is and he must
be respected all parents listening to me
yes children are children I know that
but do all you can to monitor your
children in church the church is not a
playground that's where we got to
worship God and God demands
reverence and it appears to me from what
you have just that part of it is
training ourselves learning what our
beauty is from scripture then we will be
able to know what is a responsibility of
our children absolutely thank you next
one is um how can someone know when the
Holy Spirit has come upon him or her
especially when the person has been
praying for that if a person is filled
with the Holy Spirit the person's
primary urge is to do whatever pleases
God and what pleases God
is expressed in Ecclesiastes 12:13 let
us hear the conclusion of the whole
matter for God and keep his Commandments
for this is the whole duty of man a
person led by the spirit of God has one
overriding urge to obey God and to
produce through that Spirit enabled
obedience the fruits of the spirit if
the spirit of God is in you your primary
desire is to do what pleases God and to
obey him
thank
you in other words obedience is the only
reliable evidence of conversion and the
presence of the spirit obedience
obedience next one is are animals
required to obey God and if not why was
the serpent in Genesis 3 cursed no
animals are not required to obey the Ten
Commandments but keep in mind God placed
all creation under Adam's Dominion so
when Adam sinned his sin offend ected
the entire creation you see now the
serpent was cursed by God yes the
serpent is part of
creation whatever God does is right
that's a fundamental principle even if
we don't understand whatever God does is
Right Psalm 145 verse 17 the Lord is
righteous in all his ways and holy in
all his words he cannot do wrong so if I
with my limited intellect cannot
understand what God does it does not
make God wrong nor is God obligated to
explain everything to me in detail when
Adam sin the entire creation came under
the curse of God that of course included
the serpent animals you know I love
going to Parks
safaris but let me tell you something
life in National Parks is frightening
animals killing each other lions hunting
gazelle crocodiles catching those
crossing the river you know scorpions
stinging everywhere you go something is
killing some why is that the curse of
sin how did that come about Adam the
supervisor of creation he sinned and the
curse of sin the rebelliousness that
Adam developed as a result of sin it
passed to the Animal Kingdom but animals
are not required to obey the Ten
Commandments but animals obey God God
commanded Ravens to feed
Elijah uh First Kings 61 17 God can
command Locust to Devour the land 2
Chronicles 7:13 he can do that he can
command the clouds not to drop the rain
Isaiah
5:6 they obey him but they're not called
upon to obey the Ten Commandments those
are moral Commandments they are reserved
for intelligent beings human beings and
angels all right thank
you does Colossians 2:16 say that we
shouldn't keep the Sabbath and shouldn't
observe dietary laws and related to that
is Romans 14 ver14 MH the question being
does do these verses mean that somebody
can eat anything well let's go to
Colossians chapter 2:16 a very very
common verse used by people who try to
show the Sabbath need not be kept but
that's not what the Bible is saying let
us go Romans chapter Colossians sorry
chapter 2 verse 16 and the person says
does that mean we don't have to keep the
Sabbath let their mind therefore judge
you in let no one judge you in food or
in drink or regarding a festival or a
new moon or Sabbath all right the Bible
doesn't say the first does say don't
keep it it said don't let anyone judge
you that is not a statement prohibiting
the observance of the Sabbath but read
verse 17
now which are a shadow of things to come
you that the word Shadow connects all of
that to the sanctuary system the entire
Sanctuary system was a shadow of things
to come and so we read in 1 Corinthians
5:7 Christ Our Passover is CR crucified
for us the sac the Passover sacrifice
was a shadow of something to come and
the Fulfillment was Calvary when the
ultimate Passover was sacrificed all the
sacrificial activities and and
sacrifices and rituals there were a
shadow the entire Century itself was a
shadow of the original in heaven now a
shadow of things to come the Sabbath is
not a shadow of things to come the
Sabbath is a memorial of something past
which is creation not a shadow of
something to come now go to 1
Corinthians 7 read verse 19 let me show
you what the same Paul says because it's
Paul in Colossians 21:16 who says let no
man judge you in observance of a holy
day listen to what the same Paul says in
1 Corinthians
7:19 7:19 he says circumcision is
nothing and uncircumcision is nothing
but keeping the Comm
and that includes the seventh day
Sabbath what matters so the same Paul
says what really matters is not being
circumcised now when Paul said that keep
in mind to whom he's writing the Jews
were so fixed on circumcision the word
was used to refer to them they were
called the circumcision because it was
such a central part of their lives and
to have Paul say circumcision is nothing
is to have Paul say your culture is
nothing you know it's like telling the
Messi and he Africa cows are nothing you
know you can't do that but Paul says
circumcision is nothing uncircumcision
is nothing what really counts is keeping
the Comm he said he didn't say keeping
nine he said keeping the commandments so
that Paul in First Corinthians 7:19
cannot reverse his words in Colossians
2:16 Colossians 21:16 does not forbid
the keeping of the Sabbath it says don't
let prisons judge you but keep in mind
there are several s ceremonial sabbaths
in the Bible they're all listed in
Leviticus 23 and they all are attached
to the seven annual Feast we have
Passover number one Feast of 11 bread
Feast of first fruit Feast of Weeks day
of trumpet day of atonement Feast of
Tabernacles in that order spring
festivals fall festivals they all teach
us about salvation from the time you
accept Christ to when you enter the
kingdom Colossians 2:16 does not forbid
the observance of the Sabbath day
because Paul tells us clearly what
really comes with God is to live
according to his
Commandments okay and Romans 14:14 okay
let's go to that Romans 14:14 14 listen
to the same Paul Paul writes to say I
know that I'm convicted I'm convinced by
the Lord Jesus that there is nothing
unclean in itself right pause there's
not there's nothing unclean in itself
about a pig because God made Pig PS
there's nothing unclean in itself about
a dog God made dogs there's nothing
unclean in itself about a lion God made
L but when it comes to diet those
animals are not fit for food in that
sense they're unclean are you with me
but God never deliberately makes an
unclean thing because the Bible tells us
in Genesis 1:31 and God saw everything
that he had made including pigs lion
snakes and he saw that it was very good
so we must reason
when with respect to diet don't eat a
snake with respect to diet don't eat a
slug you see but God made these things
to fulfill their functions in nature but
when you take them out of their function
and have them function as a dietary item
that's where you get into trouble they
were not made to be actually none of the
animals were made to be eaten let me be
frank before sin none after sin God
restricts now you may eat these but not
those
and we have unclean animals going all
the way back to um Genesis chter 7 when
the animals went into the ark Genesis 7:
2 and 3 clean and clean clean and clean
way back before there were any
Israelites and so any animal is not good
for food some people think that's what
the verse is saying M no animal is
unclean in and of itself it is the youth
to which we put that animal that
introduces uncleanness and when used for
food even though it's banned by by God
that's where uncleanness becomes a
reality all right next one we have what
is solar scri scriptura solar scriptura
is an expression used by the reformers
in the days of Martin Luther and
mington it simply means the Bible only
the Bible and the Bible only that's the
principle Martin Luther and reformers
used to challenge the Catholic teaching
that justification by faith is not by
faith alone but by faith and partially
your own Works Martin Luther said no by
faith alone and this is based on the
Bible the Bible alone the Catholic
Church uses tradition plus the Bible
they said no solar scriptura the Bible
and the Bible alone that's what solar
scriptura mean then they solar feed by
faith alone they had about five of these
saying but solar scripture simply means
the Bible and the Bible
alone thank you how can I be a
missionary in a new country for instance
an an Islamic country an Islamic country
all right everyone on the face of the
earth needs to hear the gospel whether
Islamic country Buddhist country
whatever confucianist
country you have to be sure this is
God's will for you never go where God
didn't send you it may look like a good
idea let me go to some Islamic country
and preach Jesus Christ fine it may look
like a good idea God may not want you
there's Peter there's Paul God sent
Peter to the Jews he sent Paul to the
Gentiles you see he he he he prepared
them and made them suited for different
groups of people so God may not want you
so make sure you're seeking God's will
you want to go to Islamic country what
are you doing right where you are to
develop the skills what are you doing in
your neighborhood in your church in your
town in your city in your village to
spread the gospel are you practicing the
skills of evangelism where you are
before you go off into strange
environment where people know nothing
about Christ and try to preach Christ
remember ye shall be Witnesses unto me
in Jerusalem and Judea and Samaria the
utmost parts of the earth so start at
home do what you can show God what
you're willing to do then God may move
you to some area where you desire to go
and there is this period where Paul I
believe in act 16 where he wants to go
to a given place for Mission and God
says you can't go the spirit said yes
God said no and that's the need for us
to surrend our plans to him and ask him
to guide us even if the plan looks good
David wanted to build a temple for God
excellent idea God said no not you let
Solomon do it so the fact it's a good
idea does not mean God wants you to do
it he may want someone else to do it all
right thank
you how can I memorize the Bible and for
those who speak more than one language
which language would do you recommend
how can one memorize the Bible there's
one fundamental principle constant
repetition over and over and
over what book do I recommend for uh did
you say book or language language oh the
language in which you're strongest yeah
for those who speak more than one yeah
well the your most basic language if
it's English use English if it's French
use French the one in which you're
strongest and most uh skillful use that
language but the principle for
memorization the most fundamental
principle is constant repe when you're
brushing your teeth recite when you're
taking a shower recite when you're
driving recite when you're whatever
waiting in line in the bank a queue
recite all the time occupy your mind
with the word of God and the more you do
it the better it becomes and one my
favorite writer says that which it first
seems Difficult by constant repetition
grows easy and that's absolutely true
constant repetition ask God to help you
because God wants you to memorize Psalm
119 verse1 Thy word have I hid in my
heart that I might not sin against thee
God wants that word hidden in your mind
so you have it under all situations and
at all occasions but con now of course
you can write on uh 3x five cards you
can sing it singing is one excellent way
to memorize the Bible I don't do it that
way but God deals with it differently
writing it out then you interact
physically with the word visually you
look at it you may listen to recording
then that's auditory then you write it
that kinesthetic so you have visual
auditory kinesthetic the more senses you
bring the more effectively you anchor
the word of God in your mind I'm very
delighted with that person who wants to
memorize God God's word I urge all of
you listening make an effort and because
I'm very biased I recommend the King
James version all right and may I add
that have the right motive to have the
right don't do it to show off don't do
that do it to glorify God and to have a
source of spiritual power amen thank you
I mean don't just memorize it obey it
this is not a PO by Shakespeare this is
the Living Word of God obey it memorize
it obey it and use it to encourage
someone else amen all right how do I
make things that require discipline for
instance Bible study don't feel not to
feel like a
chore it depends on how important that
thing is to
you people say to me all the time how do
you don't you get tired of traveling and
flying and I said no because I'm doing
what I love to do when you love to do
something is not a chure it is simply
self-expression so when I stand In a
Pulpit I'm just expressing myself when
I'm on a plane going to some distant
part of the world to preach for God this
is just who I am and so if you have a
responsibility to take care of if it's
important to you it will not be a chore
so you have to connect it to is this
God's will for me how will this glorify
God everything we do must come down to
the glory of God whether therefore you
eat or drink or whatsoever you do 1
Corinthians 10:31 one do all to the
glory of God Is This For the Glory of
God if it is and your life is
surrendered to God it becomes a task of
delight not a CH when the disciples were
beaten Peter and John for preaching
Christ in Acts chapter 4 they left
rejoicing that they were counted worthy
to suffer for the cause of Christ they
left rejoicing they' been
whipped because the motivation was
different and so whatever responsibility
you have discipline tells you get to it
but the motivation must be the glory of
God first and foremost okay thank you by
the way a Christian must be a
disciplined
person if you ask to sing special music
rehearse practice don't just jump up and
say God understand don't be ill
disciplined rehearse practice we must be
disciplined people and a disciplined
person accomplishes much more than one
who is not disciplined even though that
person may be a genius but not
disciplined that person cannot fulfill
his or her potential okay thank
you are children born out of wedlock
cursed and um Can such children claim
the promise given to Jeremiah in
Jeremiah 1 I believe verse 5 verse five
yes a child born out of wedlock is not a
sin wish I can say that in all the
languages on the face of the earth a
child is not a sin fornication is a sin
adultery is a sin homosexuality is a sin
lesbianism is a sin beastiality is a sin
a child in a woman's womb is not a sin
that has made very clear people ask me
sometime can I dedicate should we
dedicate a child born out of wedlock yes
that child is given Life by God God
could have cut life off in the womb but
he didn't he allowed that child to live
so a child is not a sin and if you're in
that condition and I speak respectfully
the child you're carrying is not a sin
if you confess your sin to God God
forgives and he forgets commit that
child to God raise that child for the
glory of God now can the child benefit
from jeremiah: 15 if Jeremiah 15 says
before I formed you in the belly I knew
you and before th came is form out of
the womb I sanctify thee and I ordained
the prophet unto the Nations yes if God
gives you life he allows you to live he
will give you a purpose mhm God never
gives life
aimlessly if he allows you to live he's
given you life he attaches a purpose the
way you came into existence may not have
been his way but since he allowed you to
live and I have to keep saying that he
allowed you to live he will give you a
purpose M okay and so please a baby in a
mother's womb is not a sin m makes me
think of ishma and God says I'll bless
him he wasn't part of my plan right but
I'm going to make him a
great y very good very thank you okay
all right how should H Seventh Day
Adventist parents and also by extension
the church deal with those who have
special needs the greatest special need
is the need the sinner has for Jesus
Christ and God put everything in place a
church is a place where people are
unselfish in their Devotion to one
another
if there's one member with a special
need the whole church must be concerned
you simply can't say that's his business
M the whole chur you see Paul compares
the church to a human body they the toes
they the fingers whatever clearly the
brain and the heart are the most
important you can lose a finger and
you're fine but Paul says if a little
member suffers the whole body must
suffer if you shoot me my finger you've
shot me you haven't simply shot my
finger you have shot me if someone came
to me which of your fingers would you
like me to cut off none which of your
toes none which of your toenails would
you love me to pull out with a pliers
none and so if one member of the church
is suffering the whole church must come
together to ease that person suffering
because the whole church must suffer
with that person we have many churches
where they members who are suffering and
members don't care or didn't notice or
not aware if one member
suffers the whole church must suffer in
other words if one member has a special
need the entire church comes together to
provide that need for that person okay
that's love in the church and that's a
church can't solve every problem but the
church will make its best effort yeah
because Christ values that
person yeah and that's what exactly
Jesus did well he was on the face of the
Earth he saw the needy and reached out
to them responded mhm mhm mhm all right
and is it true that you can't stop
sinning and as long as you living in the
sinful world that's absolutely not true
that's adoption of the devil there's no
such thing as you cannot stop sinning
now you cannot stop the devil from
tempting you but you can decide I will
not offend God Daniel decided I will not
pray to a man I prefer to be eaten by
lions the three Hebrew boys decided we
prefer to burn alive than bow to an
image there are people in the Bible
who've chosen death rather than sin
against God and so you can stop sinning
by the power of God yes that's God's
desire now unto him that is able to keep
you from falling you see and the power
of Christ is able to do that but it must
be our great desire our great desire it
does not happen automatically we must
fight the good fight of Faith daily
first uh Timothy 6: 12 fight the good
fight of faith it does not happen
automatically Galatians 5:17 the flesh
lusteth against the spirit and the
spirit against the flesh but the battle
is
winnable the battle is winnable constant
surrender of to life to God staying in
the word of God Thy word have I hi in my
heart that I might not sin against thee
uh Psalm 119 verse uh 11 verse 9 where
with all shall a young man cleanse his
ways never get rid of sin by taking he
there according to Thy word John 15:3
Jesus told the disciples now you clean
through the word clean from what sin
which I have spoken unto you Jesus
prayed in John 17:1 15 I pray not that
thou shal take them out of the world but
that thou shal keep them from the evil
can God keep us from the evil Jesus
prayed and told the father do that then
he tells the father how to do it verse
17 sanctify them through thy truth Thy
word is truth we can come to the place
where we no longer sin not we cannot sin
we choose not to sin by the grace and
power of God by grace of God and that
Grace is administered through the word
and the spirit in other words if we
think we can't stop sinning we are
limiting the power of God yes we're
telling God you don't have the power MH
all
right coming to the next one is did
Lucifer rebel against God before or
after the creation of the human race if
you use the biblical evidence we look at
the chronology of creation the tree of
the knowledge of Good and Evil was made
on the third
day okay okay Adam was made on the sixth
if the tree of the knowledge of Good and
Evil was made on the third day sin
existed before Adam was
made on the basis of that alone we see
there's the presence of sin in the
universe before Adam was made and so yes
Lucifer rebelled before the world was
created M all right thank you should I
repent after I have heard a bad dream
okay I don't have a commandment for that
what I do know here's what I do and I'm
not setting myself up as an example we
must never think we're too
good never think I don't need to
confess if I dream and I sin in my dream
as soon as I wake up I confess that sin
because it tells me that thing I dream
is something I could easily do you you
follow me and so while I don't have a
Bible verse I recommend as a servant of
God if you sinned in your dream you lose
Nothing by saying father I am sorry
because this shows me what I'm capable
of
doing you lose nothing never come to the
place where you think I don't have to
confess don't ever come to that point
yeah and it could also be a moment for
you to say God is there sin in me search
my heart and there be
anything remove it Psalm 139: 23-24
search me God what is there in my mind
during the day that produced that dream
yeah mhm thank you and um we have one
more uh is there a Bible verse that
shows that Cain knew he was supposed to
offer an animal for a sacrifice and
chose not to okay here's where we have
to reason together did Cain know what
God wanted now God does not execute
judgment on someone who's ignorant let's
go to John 15
mhm read John 15 let's read verse 22 and
verse 23 of verse 24 here what Jesus
tells uh his disciples John 15 verse 22
and verse 24 John 15 22 reads if I had
not come and spoken to them right they
had not had sin would not they would
have no sin that's right in other words
they had no
knowledge where knowledge is absent God
does not charge a person with sin even
though the person does something wrong
the person is not charged but we know
that Cain was condemned by God so Cain
had to have known read verse 24 24 reads
if I had not done among them The Works
which no one did they would have no sin
in other words I spoke to them I did
Works they had evidence from me
consequently their Works amounted to sin
go to John chapter
9 let's read verse 41
read 39 to
41 then and Jesus said for judgment I
come into this world MH that those who
do not see who do not see may see and
that those who see may be made blind yes
now listen to the Pharisees and the Jews
then some of the Pharisees who were with
him who who heard um who were with him
heard these words and said to himh are
we blind also listen to Jesus now and
Jesus said to them if you are blind M
you would have no sin but now you say we
see know Therefore your sin remain your
sin remain was charged with sin because
he knew that's a principle of God you
see God does not execute judgment where
someone is ignorant in the days of your
ignorance he Winks he Winks act
17:30 yeah he Winks in the time of
ignorance he could not wink at Cain Cain
knew clearly taught by his father as
what he should have brought and he
didn't that's why God said look do
what's right God can't say do what's
right without telling you he said if you
do what's right I'll receive you that's
what he said to him in Genesis chter 4
verse verse 6 if you do what's right and
so he he knew and God had to pass
judgment on him M God does God is such a
nice person he does not hold you guilty
in times of ignorance but God does not
glorify ignorance he wants people to
know the verse we use acts 173
in the time of this ignorance God winked
at but now commandeth men everywhere to
repent he wants you to know because
ignorance has no ven no
benefits why did Jesus wait until he was
30 to begin his
ministry it could be that in the Jewish
system priests began their duties at the
age of 30 that's when they began the
duties it could be that could be one
reason why Jesus began his ministry even
though he was not a priest on the Earth
but he would ultimately be a priest in
heaven but it could be for that reason
the Jews began their Priestly duties at
the age of 30 so Christ began his public
Ministry at the age of 30 all right
thank you what are the fruits that we
are supposed to produce according to the
Bible Well the fruits are listed in
Galatians
52223 but the fruit of the spirit is
love joy peace longsuffering gentleness
goodness Faith meekness Temperance and
verse 23 ends this way against such
there is no law in other words the law
does not condemn the fruits of the
spirit those are the fruits we're
supposed to produce and so when Jesus
told the disciples in John 158 herein is
my father glorified that you bear much
fruit those are the fruits there are no
other fruits were required to produce
but the fruits by the way notice they
called the fruits of the spirit not the
fruits of the person if you set out to
produce those fruits in your own power
you introduce yourself to fr ation they
are produced by the Spirit dwelling
within you through constant surrender
they are the fruits of the spirit only
the spirit can produce them in you but
he must do that from the inside which
requires the surrender of your life to
God
constantly okay thank you how do we
worship one God when we have God the
Father the Son and the Holy Spirit now
we worship one
God in Genesis 1:26 the the Bible says
and God said let us make man in our
image we have our which is plural but we
have image which is singular so Father
Son and Holy Spirit have the same image
it's the same Divinity is the same
Essence is the same God let us make man
in our image then you read verse 27 so
God created man in his own image so we
have his one of the group in verse 26 we
have our that's more than one one of
them actually did the creating because
verse 27 says so God created man in his
own image so we have plural in 26 we
have singular in 27 but it is always
image not images
image and so we have one Essence one
image one Divinity and we're dealing
with a subject that no human mind can
fully understand we must make that
admission whenever we discuss God the
moment you think you understand God
fully you're saying God is no longer God
but job 11:7 tells us can thou by
searching find out God can thou find out
the almighty and Perfection no one can
fully understand God you see and so we
dealing with a subject that's massive
but there are evidences in the Bible
that there three persons but one Essence
one Divinity one God
so we baptize people name of the father
name of the son name of the Holy Ghost
but it's one name okay three persons all
right so praying to Jesus is not
contradictory to praying to God no but
Jesus said pray to God because even
though they equal they have different
functions it was Jesus who came in human
form not the father not the Holy Ghost
now Jesus in human form was led by the
Holy Ghost acts 10:38 Luke 4 48 Jesus
said the spirit of God is upon me he
hath anointed me to preach the gospel so
he was led by the spirit but at the
direction of the father and so God
anointed Christ with the Holy Ghost and
with power we have all three in Acts
10:38 God anointed Christ with the Holy
Ghost and with power we have God the
Father the Holy Ghost and we have Christ
they have different functions and so
Jesus says when you pray say our father
so he tells us pray to the father now if
someone prayers to Jesus I offer no
condemnation I don't all I can tell the
person Jesus said pray to the father not
the Holy Ghost in John 17 when Jesus
prayed the entire chapter six times he
said father father F six times in John
17 not the Holy Ghost father and so they
are equal but they have different
functions when you convicted of sin it
is the holy ghost that does that that's
why the Bible says grieve not the spirit
of God not don't grieve Jesus or the
father even though they grieve when we
disobey but the power that convicts us
is the Holy Spirit and the Bible says
don't grieve him Jesus tells us in
Matthew 1231 to 32 you can blaspheme the
son and be forgiven don't blaspheme the
Holy Ghost there's no forgiveness so
there's separate beings separate
functions but one Essence one Divinity
one God okay that's as far as we can go
all right mhm was Satan being thrown
down from heaven Revelation 12:9 literal
or symbolic Revelation 12 let's read
from 7 to9 of Revelation 12 and there
was war in heaven Michael and his angels
fought against the dragon and the dragon
fought and his angels and prevailed not
neither was their place found anymore in
heaven verse n and the Great Dragon was
cast out that old serpent called the
devil and Satan which deceiveth the
whole world he was cast out into the
Earth and his angels were cast out with
him in Luke 10:18 Jesus told the
disciples I beheld Satan like lightning
fall from Heaven it was Christ who threw
him out it was a literal casting out of
the devil yes all
right someone asked by the way the same
God who cast Satan Out of Heaven Can
cast him out of your life all right
amen one asks I had a child with a
nonbeliever and currently I'm dating a
Believer okay should I marry the one I
had a child with or the one I'm
currently dating I don't mean to be
harsh but I have to be blunt you should
not have been involved with the
unbeliever in the first place whoever
you are God loves you so do I but you
should not now you cannot marry someone
simply because the woman has your child
or you cannot marry a man because he
fathered your child you marry because
the person falls under the category that
God has recommended they must be of the
same faith not only of the same Faith
but other things must be in place before
you make a decision to enter into a
union that is supposed to last for life
you know we live in an age where people
divorce though it's a it's a sport but
marriage is designed for life and so you
do not marry her simply because he has
your child don't add one wrong to
another you marry someone of the same
Faith 2 Corinthians
6:14 what be not unequally y together
with unbelievers what Fellowship have
righteousness with unrighteousness what
communion have light with Darkness it's
you don't do that yes you have to take
care of that child
yes you must because you're the father
of the child but you don't go marry her
just because she had your
child a child is no justification for
marriage it must be according to God's
Will and God's plan in his Bible so do
not marry her just because she had your
child and she's an unbeliever marry a
Believer I mean a genuine believer not
just someone who sits in a PE a genuine
believer who lives according to the
principles of righteousness all right
but as I said take care of that child it
is still yours and God loves that child
okay does God
laugh let's go to Psalm two I almost did
not answer that question but I thought
let me answer it does God laugh we go to
Psalm 2 we read from verse one of we'll
go to 1 to 4 of Psalm 2 and discover if
God last wherefore do the Heathen rage
and the people imagine you can for a
vain thing while do the Nations rage and
the people plot a vain thing the kings
of the earth set themselves and the
rulers take counsel together against the
Lord and against his anointed saying let
us break their Bonds in pieces and Cast
Away their cord from now listen to four
he in the heavens shall laugh at them
mhm the Lord shall
yes so the Bible suggests God laughs
when the final judgment is poured out
something will come out of him some
expression that looks like laughter now
God does not make fun of people but that
verse say he that sits to Heaven shall
laugh at them
mhh sometimes I remember my past sins
and also we're made in the image of God
mhm so the capacity to laugh yeah
perhaps exist with God as well all
right all right next is does sometimes I
remember my past sins and I really feel
bad thinking that God is still angry
with me what should I do you believe
what God has told you we must believe
God's word not base our spiritual lives
on how we feel because feelings change
with the weather the Bible tells us
clearly 1 John 1:9 if we confess our
sins he is faithful and just to forgive
us our sins and to cleanse us from all
unrighteousness now if you don't believe
believe that you are effectively calling
God a liar by not believing his word
there are many people perhaps listening
to me now who are walking around with a
burden of guilt because they have not
accepted God's forgiveness God has not
called you to forgive yourself only God
can forgive sin you cannot forgive
yourself forgiveness is what God does
forgiveness of sin you can tell a person
okay I don't hold it against you but to
remove Sin from the soul to remove guilt
only God can do that and God God has
promised I will forgive you let's see a
beautiful passage in the Bible let's go
to Jeremiah Jeremiah chapter 3 we shall
read 12 and 13 of Jeremiah chapter 3
listen to these beautiful words and
believe them read for us my pastor only
acknowledge your 12 13 12 13 go and
Proclaim these words toward the Lord say
return backsliding Israel says the Lord
I will not call my anger fall on you
that's right for I am merciful says the
Lord I will not remain angry forever
only now notice the word only do what
acknowledge your iniquity that you have
transgress against so God is saying look
come to me and
admit I'm wrong only acknowledge come to
God and say father ah I stole that money
I am wrong forgive me father I lied I am
wrong in other words as we say in United
States come clean mhm come clean but the
policeman points gante to you throw both
hands up God say throw your hands up and
say okay God you got me you've I am
wrong it's hard for the carnal nature to
say I am wrong and so God says only
acknowledge your iniquity that you've
transgressed against the Lord and you do
that he forgives you and he forgets
right but we don't forgive people you
see so we throw that attitude upon God
and we assume God does not forgive but
God forgives he loves to forgive Micah
7:18 he delighteth in Mercy and the
greatest act of Mercy is forgiveness
based on the sacrifice of Jesus Christ
whoever that person is God has forgiven
you believe it accept it and live as
though you are forgiven don't walk
around with the sins you've
confessed so our duty is to confess and
believe and believe exercise our faith
he has forgiven us he does not lie
amen next we have uh if God deserves the
glory and praise based on not based on
our
feelings will he still get glorified if
we serve him unwillingly yes God can be
glorified if you serve him unwillingly
now you get no spiritual benefit but you
can unwillingly conduct a Bible study
and someone is baptized God gets the
glory but you receive no spiritual
benefit you see because the motivation
is important to God the motive why did
you do it that's why many people will
say in the Judgment did we not prophesy
in thy name and in thy name have cast
out Devils thy name done many wonderful
works then will I profess unto them
depart from me I never knew you ye that
work iniquity and so the motivation is
important but yes God can get the glory
from service rendered unwillingly but
the person who does it unwillingly is
not spiritually blessed okay MH
if Robben was the only one who was
merciful to his brother
Joseph why did Jesus come from the line
of Judah God can do whatever he wants
the question is if Reuben the oldest of
Jo Jacob's son was the one who showed
Mercy to Joseph and he told the brothers
don't kill him let's sell him into
slavery God didn't have to choose Ruben
God does whatever he wants Psalm 115:3
but our God is in the heavens he hath
done whatsoever he pleased that Daniel
4:35 but all the inhabitants of the
Earth are reputed as nothing he doeth
according to his will in the army of
heaven and among the inhabitants of the
earth and none can stay his hand or say
unto him what doest thou you can't tell
God what are you doing God does whatever
he wants he is Sovereign now the the the
practice in the Bible was the first born
was the the the the favored son you see
the first born God went against that
Noah had three sons God chose Shem as
the line through Christ would come the
oldest boy was japheth not Shem Abraham
AA had three boys Abraham n and Heron
Abraham was the youngest God chose
Abraham Isaac had two sons and in the
womb God chose the younger of the two in
the womb so we can't tell God what God
can do whatever he wants even it goes
contrary to human practices so the fact
that Reuben was the one who showed Mercy
to Joseph did not obligate God to choose
Reuben we cannot tell God what to do God
chose
Judah number four in the line of the
boys that were born to Jacob God does
whatever he wants and to add to that
would be to say Reuben was not sinless
either Ruben wasn't sinless no of course
neither was Judah but God chose Judah he
chose Judah all right and by the way to
to to extend that the priests were to
come from Levi Christ our high priest
came from came from Judah not Levi so
God can go contrary to human practices
MH and still be right all right what is
the right age to start dating and is it
right to date while in college and or
university depends on your age you're 14
and 15 what are you dating for I mean
your child when God put Adam and Eve
together he put a man and a woman he
didn't put a boy and a girl are you with
me he put a man and a woman not a boy
and a girl and so dating is not for
children dating is for those who are on
the edge of adulthood for instance you
know God has given us the number seven
is the number of perfection let me go
slow on this seven is the number of
perfection now the teenage years are
seven 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 you have
seven perfect years to learn to be an
adult and so my recommendation I have no
Bible verse my recommendation is in your
later teens you can think of dating 18
19 when you you've spent some time
learning what it means to be an adult
then you consider uh dat not 13 and 12
as is the case people watch television
and they see 12 year olds with
girlfriends and every child wants a
boyfriend every little boy wants a
girlfriend you must have some level of
emotional maturity you see and other
forms of maturity to enter in a because
dating is designed to lead to marriage
it is not a recreational sport are you
with me dating is not a recreational
sport its purpose is marriage so if
that's not your purpose you shouldn't be
dating okay but when you towards the end
of that trial period of seven years
perfect time to learn to be an adult you
can consider dating But as God desires
and
guides all right and wisdom would would
also call for how do you balance School
in this case University with your dating
well you have to
prioritize didn't I come to University
to date or did I come to study M you
understand we must make tough choices
many years ago I counsel a medical
school and I would tell the students all
the time when you're in medical school
you must put on your md glasses medical
doctor here they are on this land you
have M that's Medical on this land you
have d That's doctor never take them off
so if someone were to say to you let's
go and play Let's go to a club you say
hold on you put on your glasses through
the lens of why you came you say no if
you take them off and lose your focus
you say yes to everything and so if
you're in school pursuing a degree did
you come to the university to date no
you came to study now a relationship May
develop yes but if you're led by God God
will take care of that but you're there
to study and that is your focus and if
dating interferes with your studying you
have to give up the dating all right
prioritizing is not easy
mhm because you've got to leave your
feelings
out what's important why am I at the
school why I'm in medical school why am
at the University am I paying tution why
am I paying tuition why my parents
sacrificing so much why and you keep
this in mind all right M okay next one
is um should teenagers over 18 think
about leaving the seventh day Adventure
Church no one of any age should think of
leaving the Seventh Day Advent church if
you study what we believe honestly if
you reason through the scriptures we
have a system of truth that is 100%
biblical don't leave
whether you go over 18 or under six
don't leave when the disciples were
leaving Christ in John 665 from that
time 66 many of disciples went back and
walked no more with him and Jesus said
to the 12 will he also go away Peter
said Lord to whom shall we go thou Hast
the words of eternal life he stayed and
the 12 stayed because of what Jesus
said your church should be chosen on the
basis of what the church teaches not the
size of the organ how loudly the choir
sings how many people speak in tongues
what does the church Preach is it
biblical don't leave you the 7day
Adventist Church and where you
going okay watch your ages don't leave
all right next uh spirit of Prophecy
questions um first one is what elen G
white books do you recommend on the
topics of the Holy Spirit and uh knowing
uh known sins and their consequences as
well as over coming those sins I
recommend two books one steps to
Christ if there were no Bibles available
on this Earth no books at all of any
kind and I were given a choice to pick
one book to live with for the rest of my
life it will be steps to Christ the
other recommendation The Desire of Ages
those two books are the ones I recommend
highly to the person who paed the
question all right what are the unfallen
worlds is this truth found in the Bible
or just in spiritual prophecy there are
there's a hint or hints in the Bible for
instance Revelation
12:12 therefore Rejoice ye heavens and
thee that dwell in them W to the
inhabitants of the earth and of the sea
for the devil has come down unto you
having great wrath because he knoweth
that he hath but a short time listen to
how the verse begins therefore Rejoice
ye heavens and ye that dwell in them the
Bible consistently talks talks about
Heavens in job 1:6 now it was a day when
the sons of God came to present
themselves before the Lord there are
clear evidences in Scripture that there
are inhabitants of other worlds that
meet with God regularly and Satan came
to meet with him as the representative
of this Earth because Satan came also
among them also job chap 2:1 again there
was a day when these Representatives
come so we have evidence from the Bible
that there are worlds where people live
who have never sinned okay and if we're
faithful one day when Christ sets up
this new world we'll be able to visit
them and this is literal not symbolic
we'll be able to visit them
okay Ellen White says that every Act is
judged by the motive that prompts it m
could you please elaborate what this
means let's go to Mark chapter 7 Mark 7
we read 20 to 21 listen carefully to The
Words of Christ then we'll go to Matthew
12 we'll read uh 34 33
3435 we're looking at Mark 7 verse 20
what does verse 20 say and he said what
and he said what comes out of man uhhuh
that defiles okay now in other words
adultery comes out of
here hatred comes out of here pride
comes out of here it goes from the
inside out mhm even if you'd never do it
physically you've done it because it
comes out of here this is where motives
are and so let's go to Mark let's go to
to Matthew 12 let's read verse
33 let's Matthew 12:33 hear what that
verse when we go to
34 1234 reads 33 33
M either make the tree good and its
fruits its fruits good or else make the
tree bad and it fruit bad for a tree is
known by its fruit okay what it produced
Now read 34 BR of vipers how can you
being speak good things for out of out
of the abundance of the mouth speak what
comes from here originates here what
comes from here originates here read
verse 35 a good man a good man out good
treasure treasure of his heart brings
forth good things yes this is the origin
this is where M this is what determines
the character of an act why did now for
instance here's a man he's wealthy he
gives $1 million to the church and all
the church members this amen amen they
don't understand he just wants his name
on a plaque you see God sees that and he
gets no spiritual benefit from God now
God will use the money the money is his
but that man gets no credit from God not
because his motive was wrong but no
human being can see that and so the
servant of the Lord tells us in Christ
object lessons page 316 paragraph 2
Every Act is judged by the motive why
did you do that why but that applies on
the earth you see when there's a crime
investigators search first for a motive
why did he the motive will determine the
the character of the ACT is it
manslaughter or first-degree murder what
was the motive he came to the house to
steal he strug with the house owner the
house owner had a gun in the struggle he
took the gun and shot him that's
manslaughter now if he came to the house
with a gun he had a different motive you
see is more than theft and so motive
determines the quality of an act and so
we keep the Sabbath for the right motive
the glorify God we return a tithe for
the right motive not so God will give us
money because God said do it to glorify
God everything we do what's the motive
the glory of God without exception my
good pastor all right thank you you very
much is there a conflict between 1
Timothy 4:3 and Ellen White's teaching
on health let's go to 1 Timothy chter
4:3 we shall read from verse 1 of 1
Timothy chapter 4 now the spirit
speaketh expressly that in the latter
times some shall depart from the faith
you can pick it up from verse two verse
two speaking lies in hypocrisy having
their own conscience seared with now
listen to verse three forbidding to
marry and commanding to obain from foods
which God created to be received with
Thanksgiving by those who believe and
know the truth now read verse four for
every creature of God is good and
nothing is to be refused if it's
received with
Thanksgiving for it isif Sanctified by
the word of God and pray pray look at
verse three again that's why the Bible
must be read microscopically let's look
at verse three again mhm forbidding to
marry mhm and commanding to abstain from
Meats which God hath created to be
received with Thanksgiving of whom by
uh-huh those who believe know the ah so
we have a restricted population now not
the whole world because the whole world
does not believe so Paul is condemning
those who forbid what God approves
forbidding to marry and commanding to
abstain from me which God hath created
to be received with Thanksgiving of them
that believe and know the truth you know
the people of God now when you read
verse four for every creature of God is
good Every Creature means every creature
that God created for his people in verse
three not everything that lives verse
three puts restrictions on verse four
Every Creature means every creature God
has created to be received with
Thanksgiving of those that believe and
know the truth
not just the whole world and so 1
Timothy 4:3 does not contradict the
counsel we have from the spirit of
Prophecy not at all all
right finally Why don't many Adventist
churches teach medical missionary work
well we don't know statistically how
many don't or how many do is just an
assumption the good person is making now
I would imagine many
don't because it is not studied and its
importance is not understood but you
know in
um in her writings otherwi consistently
supports medical missionary work Christ
did more healing and good works for
people than he did preaching if you heal
me I'll listen to you are you following
me if I'm in pain don't tell me keep the
Sabbath get rid of my pain if I'm hungry
don't tell me let sing hymns give me
food and so medical missionary work
meets the material needs of people
people so that they become more more apt
to listen to The Gospel a starving man
cannot concentrate on the gospel a naked
man wants
clothes not prayer he wants clothes and
so the medical missionary work is
absolutely
essential and the church needs to be
aware of that but no church can be
commanded to promote medical missionary
work and so medical missionaries should
not be frustrated because this or that
church is not promoted do it where
you're able to do it do it individually
if you have the skill you do it
individually don't wait for the church
to tell you to do it because the church
didn't tell you sin you did that all by
yourself then you can by yourself make a
decision to reach out to people with
your knowledge and bless them but
churches really yes should promote
medical missionary work Christ was a
medical
missionary right it's the way to reach
people whom you otherwise would not
reach because all sick people is the
right arm of it's not the gospel it's
the right arm of the Gospel you
understand me yeah yes so I support
medical missionary work
100% m is that it for today yes that's
let me just say to those who listening I
wish I could see you wherever you are I
really wish but I don't know where you
are but wherever you are the only
intelligent way to live your life is
based on Matthew 4:4 where Jesus said to
the
man shall not live by bread alone but by
every word that proceedeth out of the
mouth of God live by this teach it to
your children apply it to every decision
you have to make if you do this God will
securely secure you not only in this
life but he will secure you for the life
to come I recommend to you I urge you
the word of God studied and obeyed will
produce in you the very image and
likeness of your savior which Bible
books would you recommend for somebody
who wants to start memorizing the Bible
oh immediately I recommend the Gospel of
John let me tell you why I recommend
John let's go to John chapter 20 we'll
read verses 30 and 31 now my favorite
Bible book is Genesis but I always
recommend John as the book to begin your
memorization Journey now listen to what
John says John chap 20: 30 and 31 he's
giving us the reason why he wrote his
book and truly Jesus did many other
signs in the presence of his disciples
which are not written in this book okay
let's pause right there and Jesus did
many other signs or miracles in the
presence of his disciples so they saw
which are not written in this book many
John said keep reading
but these are written now pause in other
words he carefully selected from all the
Miracles he saw Christ do he selected
some very carefully now why here's why
okay this were written to you that may
be that you may believe that Jesus is
the Christ the son of God and that
believing you may have life in his name
yes so John is saying I saw Jesus Christ
do a lot of things now all of them were
good Jesus never did anything bad but
even though they were all good John
looked at all the good things Christ did
in the Miracles and he chose about seven
of them there's one Miracle after Christ
Rose there's seven before he rose and he
said he included these in his book if
you study these if you read my book
which was carefully written it will
point you to Christ and eternal life and
so while all the Bible is designed to do
that but John is explicit in the reason
why he wrote so is Luke by the way in
act Luke chapter 1 the first four verses
on the book of Acts chapter one the
first few verses and so I recommend John
it's a it's also written by the disciple
closest to Christ who was John he lived
the longest and it was he to whom Christ
appeared and gave the Book of Revelation
and so I recommend John beginning with
his gospel then his Epistles 1 2 and
third John of course he also wrote the
Book of
Revelation how can one get rid of
addictions such as pornography and
masturbation some weaknesses are not
easily overcome they are all conquerable
but some are a greater challenge than
others now remember that God took 40
years to change Moses's mindset he had
grown up in Egypt he was a graduate of
the Egyptian University the Bible says
he was mighty in word and deed Acts
chapter 7:22 Moses was steep in Egyptian
education God took 40 years to change
that man to get him ready to lead the
Israelites for another 40 years it may
take a while for you to conquer but you
must believe you can conquer conquest of
any weakness begins with the surrender
of the will to God it includes removing
yourself from circumstances that make it
easy to fall into that trap but the
first step is give this to God so that
he controls it Rec MIT your life to him
daily you may also need to seek
professional help there's nothing wrong
with professional help because God gives
wisdom to all kinds of people you may
need to seek professional help but I
recommend Christian professionals to
give you counseling but whatever your
weakness is whether it's fornication
masturbation whatever it is it is
conquerable because the Bible says now
unto him that is able to keep you from
falling Jude verse 24 and so so yes
that's what I recommend all right is it
right to kiss before
marriage 1 Corinthians 1031 whether
therefore you eat or drink or whatsoever
you do do all to the glory of God the
question is why are you kissing what's
the spiritual value do you pray first
what can it lead to you understand can a
lead to B the human being is heavily
affected by
touch you want to hold hands why are you
keeping her from a ditch you're holding
hands
now you want to kiss what's next after
kiss you see a tight Embrace what's next
after that we must keep our eyes on what
an action can lead to and so we
recommend the spiritual counselors no
kissing it isn't spiritually necessary
to
kiss husband and wife yes kiss all you
want but because if he leads to
something else it's fine with God are
you with me but two single and married
people kissing the why are you kissing
why
and did you pray first can you include
God in that activity simple questions to
ask kissing is designed to fulfill
sensual desires not spiritual needs yeah
and I believe on the same line it would
be helpful to differentiate between the
kissing that goes around today and what
the Bible says
absolutely yes M it is not what we
consider a kiss today all right is it
right for a but by the way greet one
another with a kiss is not a command so
if you don't do it you haven't sinned
because some people take this holy kiss
too far so to avoid trouble you just
don't do it all right okay is it right
for a Christian to go for therapy
sessions nothing wrong with it as I said
earlier in the previous question God
gives wisdom to all kinds of people not
just his people and so we benefit from
their wisdom but again I recommend a
Christian counselor if not a 7 Day
Adventist uh research the person's
background carefully so you go and
receive counseling from someone who has
spiritual
values right and the next one is the
animal kingdom displays many sinful
traits for Renaissance fighting for food
and space is this a result of sin
absolutely the result of
sin plants have thorns because of sin
here Revelation not Revelation Genesis 3
thorns and thistles shall it Break Forth
unto thee and thou shalt eat the herb of
the field Genesis 3:17 yes the behavior
of animals the violence in the animal
kingdom there's violence even in plants
there's some plants that eat little
animals mm they trap them and they
dissolv them yes they're plants that
feed on little animals like rodents and
Beatles and whatever else that is all
the result of sin and When sin is
removed the entire system goes back to
what it's supposed to
be by the way animals don't sin they
suffer from the consequence of what Adam
did they're not charged with sin so in
the New World God won't resurrect
animals he resurrects people because he
didn't die to save animals he died to
save us he'll just make brand new
animals but he resurrects the righteous
dead okay is the seventh day Sabbath a
ceremonial Sabbath or was it abolished
on the cross the ceremonial system with
all its details was given in the
wilderness not as I said all his detail
there were a few that were practiced
before this the the wilderness
wonderings of the
Israelites the Sabbath is announced
before there was sin before there was a
sacrificial system so it cannot be a
ceremonial activity the Sabbath is one
of God's original Ten Commandments
required of us to observe according to
God's command and so it is not a
ceremonial Sabbath it will be observed
in a new world where there will be no
ceremonial activities as was practiced
in the wilderness by the Israelites the
Sabbath is one of the Ten Commandments
part of the moral a law not a ceremonial
day okay people will do anything to get
away from the Sabbath they'll do
anything they'll find any excuse to
avoid it's astonishing the attacks that
that one commandment receives that one
commandment remember the Sabbath day to
keep it holy no one attacks the other
night they always attack that one with
no evidence at all from scripture that
it has been changed yeah okay in the Ten
Commandments God refers to himself in
the first person sometimes in the third
person why is that so is this a style of
writing that practiced by the the
prophets to whom God gave Revelations
sometimes first person sometimes third
person I don't think there's any special
theological significance it's just a
style of writing for instance there are
poetic expressions in the Bible just a
style of writing Psalm 33:6 by the word
of the Lord where the heavens made and
all the hosts of them by the breath of
his mouth that's Hebrew parallelism the
first statement says exactly what the
second statement says it's just a style
of writing all
right is Sunday a holy day because Jesus
no matter what the rest the question is
it is not a holy thing but the rest of
it says because Christ Rose I am glad
Christ Rose because the dead Jesus
cannot save you but nowhere in the Bible
are we told to celebrate his day of
Resurrection as a holy day the Bible
does never says God blessed the day on
which Christ Rose he blessed the day on
which Christ rested after he created and
Christ himself blessed that day by the
way because he's the Creator the Bible
does not call upon us my listening
friends to observe the day on which
Christ Rose or the day on which he was
crucified which people call Good Friday
we're called to celebrate the Day on
which he rested and that is the seventh
day Sabbath okay why are most of God's
Remnant churches preaching smooth
messages oh are they preaching smooth
messages well I don't know what they all
preach but you know this is there's a we
live we're living in the last days which
are very perilous times we ought to be
very direct not necessarily harsh but
direct people need to understand there's
a judgment coming when I say judgment I
mean an activity in which God will wipe
out Sinners who have hard
hardheaded stubbornly resisted the
conviction of the spirit they will be
destroyed by God not accidentally
deliberately by God the way he
deliberately destroyed Sodom Gomorrah
and the ancient world in the day days of
Noah people need to know that they need
to know that there's a God who loves but
there's a God who gets angry we need to
know there's a God of Mercy there's a
god of wrath they need to be told that
we love to hear God is love love love
love love and we see God as an ancient
old senile grandfather no no no no we
serve a God who gets angry it's also an
expression of love so people need to
know directly look you need to give up
your sins or you will be lost and when
God destroyed the sinner it will be
horrible and excruciating that's one
reason he delays and delays because he
knows it will be so horrible and so my
direct message is let's put away sin by
the power of the indwelling spirit
because your only problem is sin that's
the only problem God has with us and so
smooth messages are not for it's not
what people need not now at any other
time in history we need direct so people
cannot say what did he say I said get
sin out of your
life leave that relationship in which
you're in and you're not married that's
what I said I said remember the Sabbath
day I said return the tithe I said stop
stealing I said stop cheating on your
taxes I said stop that sin will take you
to hell you can stop by the power of God
direct smooth messages only benefit
Satan yeah and it's God's call upon the
remnant people to give the trumpet this
certain give the trumpet a certain sound
mhm why is adultery the only ground for
divorce that's what the Bible gives you
see that's the reason why now the church
adds a few of reasons but the Bible's
single reason is adultery that's what
the Bible says that's that's that's
that's God's choice okay is it advisable
for 7eventh Day Adventist to work in non
seventh day organizations especially if
those environments are they don't
practice Christian rules 7 ADV can't
simply keep to themselves they have a
message to give they have for life to
demonstrate Daniel worked in an
environment that was not Hebrew when he
worked for Nebuchadnezzar then he worked
for Darius Joseph worked for Pharaoh in
an environment that was paganistic God
needs his people in environments where
the unbeliever can see so Pharaoh got to
know God somehow because of Joseph
Nebuchadnezzar came ultimately to accept
God because of
Daniel and so yes God needs his people
in environments that are not Christian
but he puts them there carefully he does
not put many he selects them carefully
those who can withstand the negative
influences that they will encounter not
everybody espcially chosen people he
selects to put them in those those
environments but yes God needs people in
non-Christian environments so that the
non-Christian the unbeliever may see
what it is like to be a Bible believing
Christian all right or Bible believing
sever of the Adventists let me be
precise
okay can a person still be saved who has
divorced and remarried more than once
anyone who repents will be saved anyone
who repents will be but things need to
be made right when you realize God's
plan was one wife one husband all the
way back to Adam and Eve what you need
to do is you need to cease physical
interaction with the other wives and
commit yourself to the first one you
married that's your wife Abraham had
relationship with Hagar Hagar was not
recognized by God as Abraham's wife only
Sarah was recognized by God as Abraham's
wife that has been made very clear you
can marry a thousand people which one
does God recognize the first one because
it's one man one woman what that man has
to do is to cease this conjugal
interaction with the others explain to
them why he's doing it he's become a
child of God he has to follow God's
leading but he cannot abandon them
because not responsible for the
situation he focuses on one that's the
first one and he takes care of the
others but you can't be practicing
polygamy knowing the truth and expect to
be saved Jesus has one wife not several
that's the church all right and our last
question for tonight is I divorced my
husband due to infidelity mhm is God's
will still for us to reconcile or to
stay
unmarried part two of it is is it sinful
to consider marrying somebody
else in a Malachi 2:16 for the Lord God
of Israel sayith that he hateth putting
away God does not like divorce Jesus
told the Pharisees in Matthew 19 5 to8
Moses because of the hardness of your
heart suffered you to put away your
wives divorce is a result of sin staying
together is God's original plan before
sin let me say it again staying together
was God's original plan and God wants us
to pursue the ideal divorce was
permitted because of sin but it was
permitted and the Bible gives the limit
which is of course adultery now can
someone who divorced reconcil yes
because when God put Adam out of the
garden the Hebrew word also means
divorce but through Christ we can be
reconciled back to God you see through
Christ so God believes in
reconciliation but as the person who
asked the question question I think it's
a lady if she divorced because the
husband broke the marriage v through
adultery then she is free and our church
teaches that to
remarry but if he wants to reconcile and
she's open to that yes because Calvary
is constant proof God loves
reconciliation but if she doesn't she
has not sinned and we can't judge her
because we're not in her shoes because
the Bible permits her to to to to to
separate because the vow was broken but
ideally if reconciliation can take place
that's good but if she decides to
remarry someone else she has not
sinned or if he decides if he was
innocent the innocent person can Remar
okay all right that brings us to the end
okay let let's tell our listeners that
you may not have heard your question
answered and it's probably causing some
little disappointment we go through the
questions carefully and decide which
questions if we answer them can be of
Maximum benefit to everyone who's
listening and not simply satisfying an
individual uh desire which is fine and
legitimate don't misunderstand us but
we're also trying to speak to non 7th
Day Adventists and we want to try
through this session to explain to them
what adventism is and so we keep these
things in mind as we select the
questions to answer we're not picking on
you if your question wasn't answered but
we pray we go through them and we say
okay this one not that one or not now at
another session so try to understand
every question cannot be dealt with but
continue sending your questions and
wherever you are on this round girth may
the Lord bless you thank you for your
interest in his word and again live by
every word that proceeds out of the
mouth of God what am I referring to the
Bible the Old and the new and we both
say from our hearts God bless you make
you a blessing to others and may God put
a double blessing on your children amen
pray for us Pastor dear heavenly father
may your name be glorified and thank you
for what you have enabled us to share
this evening we continue to pray a
blessing upon your people those who are
searching for truth oh God that you will
lead them to
yourself give out your power and wisdom
through the inspiration of the Holy
Spirit enable each one of us to
understand you better to love you to
obey you and to be prepared for your
Everlasting Kingdom thank you for Pastor
Randy kit I pray a blessing upon him and
his ministry thank you for the equipment
we have used and the church we have used
to do this ministry tonight blessing
upon this church and your people here
may you go with each one of us now and
remember us in the day of your coming
for we pray in Jesus name amen amen amen
[Music]
welcome friend to 2cbn television
network here we want to preach the
uplifted Savior we want to have quality
Bible seminars to help you dig deeper we
want to have interviews with shakers and
movers we want to have family life
marriage and youth programs we want to
have quality music we're providing
religious news happenings religious
world and health issues that face the
modern East African today God bless you
as you continue to watch 2cbn
[Music]